i'm not sure how recently he found this
out
but yo-yo ma is in his family tree i
don't know if this is a 23andme
or you met him or how far away he is are
we talking like second cousins or
30th cousins i need to know that answer
eventually so please everyone welcome
daniel chen okay so welcome everyone
uh hello uh my name is daniel i am
currently a phd student at virginia tech
studying data science education and
pedagogy in the medical biomedical and
health sciences and if you want to learn
about some of the work i've been doing
there is a website called ds4biomed.tech
which is a data science book essentially
geared towards people who work in the
biomedical sciences so it's a work in
progress
uh in the past i was an intern at our
studio where i worked on the great this
package
which is a code writer for lernard
documents and
recently i've been involved in carpentry
since 2014
so i've been an instructor since then
but recently i am a trainer so i am
someone who can train
instructors and as of the last couple
weeks
i am officially the community maintainer
lead so i help
manage all of the 50 plus lessons
through the carpentries
and like jared manch mentioned i have a
book that is a blatant ripoff of
his book which is called pandas for
everyone
today we're going to talk about tidy
evaluation and there's three main parts
quasi quotation closures and data masks
and depending on which part of tidy
evaluation we
want to work with um there's a few
topics that we need to cover like
quotation closures and environments
so we're going to be using d plier as an
example because it's something we're
familiar with
and i know the talk said we're going to
talk about d plier
like all of the player but in reality
we're really just going to be using the
dplyr select function
and so the data set that we'll be
working with is the
famous polymer penguins dataset and the
first thing we're going to be covering
is uh how do we select columns as a
review
so in base r we can select columns using
the regular square bracket method
so we can say row column and there's a
parameter called drop if we have a
single column we can put in
uh our column name in string and then if
it's a regular data
frame not a table we have to specify
drop equals false
and that's how we get a data frame
object back otherwise we get a vector
tables have this tables and data frames
if we need to select multiple columns
we can pass in a little vector of two
things and then we can select multiple
columns
another way we can select columns is
using a dollar sign so we can use the
dollar sign
or a single column with drop equals true
and then we'll get a vector object back
um in base r there is a subset function
that sort of behaves very similar to d
plier
in the sense that we don't have to put
quotations around the
columns that we want we can just use the
column names as is
and then the thing that we've all very
accustomed to
is the dplyr select function that
i don't really have to go into more
detail about but
one other thing that's really important
is another way you can subset columns
it's not really
advised when you're doing analytics work
but
you can subset columns based off of the
actual index position like the number
and we'll see where that comes into play
so first things first what is quasi
quotation
and the thing we have to learn is
actually what is quoting so what is an
expression uh so the r code that you
write actually
is really composed of two things it's
like the code that you write you hit
enter r takes that code
runs it and it gives you an answer so
when we type three plus three we get
six but there's a base r function called
quote
and if we say quote three plus three
instead of evaluating it
we get back the code three plus three
and so we can save that to a variable
and then there's a base r function
called eval and then
that's sort of the premise of lazy
evaluation where we're taking an
expression
and evaluating it later so you can think
of an expression like
the string representation of your code
but it's not really because it's its own
object but it's a pretty
reasonable approximation when you're
trying to think about this stuff
so where does our land come into play
our lane has a function called
exper for expression so we can do the
same thing pass in
three plus three we get three plus three
and then we can evaluate that expression
using base r
or in our length there's a function
called eval underscore tidy
and that'll do the evaluation on that
expression through our lang
and so expressions can be different
things they can be a call a symbol a
constant or a pair list
those are all really just implementation
details under the hood
so if i say like three plus three uh
you'll see that i'll get a language
object back
um but if i put in three than uh just a
number i'll get a number
object and then if i put in like
something you'll get like a symbol so
you can quote things but under the hood
you might it's like
stored a little bit differently and so
how do we
select columns so like i said before we
can pass in a direct string into a
column
um so we can pass in species directly or
we can save species into a variable and
pass that into
our data set directly but
if we pass in species on its own you'll
see that you'll get an
error that says species not found right
and that's because it's not saved to a
variable it's trying to evaluate it and
it doesn't exist
so in a typical this is sort of just a
special thing with tibbles
but you can pass in these quoted name
objects and tables and it'll work
right so tables have this additional
feature that uh
doesn't work with regular plain data
frame objects
so if we try to do that in a regular
data frame you'll see that like for
example i'm using the iris data set
uh if i try the same subset on a
data.frame it doesn't exactly work on
the table so these are things that we
have to think about so let's write our
first
selection function on our own it takes
in a data set and then a column
and then all we're doing just like
before we're saying data using regular
square bracket notation and putting drop
equals false so we always get a data
frame back
and this is nothing special right we
passed in a string column we get a
column back right and
it works in tables if we put in quotes
but like i said
it won't really work um if we
just pass in species on its own because
it's trying to evaluate that right
but i just showed you how to quote
inputs right so
let's use that quote function that we
just uh learned about and let's quote
the actual column that comes in
but then we find out that no that
doesn't exactly work because when we
wrote quote
call what actually got passed into data
is actually
col not species right so it actually
quoted the thing that we told it to
quote which is exactly what we told the
computer to do
so that's a problem in our lang there is
a function called
an exper or enriched expression and you
use this function
inside of a function to sort of handle
that like hey i want you to quote this
thing but don't quote the variable or
the function parameter i gave you
actually quote the thing that the user
passed in
right and so there's um
we use nxper for that
so we can use nxper for our third
attempt at this so instead of using
um quoting we're putting n exper and
then now if we put in
species without a quote it'll do that
for us
and we can save this object to another
variable and then
pass that in along the way
but if we pass this into a data frame
object
it doesn't exactly work properly because
tables have that additional feature that
data frames don't have
so the way we handle this more generally
is we use the index position
so we take the whatever the user passed
in
and then we write some regular r code
that essentially says hey
look through all of the column names in
our data set find the ones that match
and then subset on the index directly
and then we get the same exact features
for both sides we can say
passing species for a typical or you can
pass in species that's un
that's the quote for data frame we both
get the same result
and that's weird thing of like using the
index position um if you sort of dig
your way and follow the
deployer source code it pretty much does
something
like that you'll see that there's this
match call that ends up calling this vec
as location so
under the hood dplyr is doing something
very similar
so now we want to expand this how do we
get it to work with multiple variables
um so in we before we showed you a
function called nxper
so if we put an s at the end of it for n
experts
it will be able to capture essentially
dot dot
and then what we get back is a list of
expressions that was passed in for dot
dot dot
so what i did was uh we have a list of
expressions convert it to a character
and then do regular r things to get the
index position
and then subset that way and you'll see
it works for both a table and a data
frame
uh the thing that i noticed when i first
wrote through this um
i wrote which instead of match and the
difference between that
is uh if i used which it didn't
it preserved the same order of the
original data frame regardless of what i
used in
uh and if we use match it'll if we
specify the columns in a different order
it'll give you back the data frame in
the order you specify so
that's the little difference between
there so
what is exactly is quasi quotation which
is essentially quoting
unquoting and re-quoting so before
our last attempt we use nx experts to
like handle the weirdness that's going
on
uh we turned it into a character string
and then we did regular r things with it
so variables um can be both quoted and
unquoted uh so we can say like okay now
we want
column as species as the variable
and we want to pass that in as one of
the column names for
selection and you can see right now in
our current function
we can do that in base r
and we can do the same thing in d player
um
using d plier select and then we get a
little warning that's saying that it's
like evaluating a thing
but it's only a warning that's once per
session so
so we want to be able to mimic that
behavior
so we can do that
our function right now if we take in uh
penguins and pass in island and year we
can
we can do that but right now it doesn't
want
it doesn't exactly work if we pass in
call name right because we can
send species as a variable to call name
but
it's not working uh properly right now
because it's
uh trying to pick up like c-o-l-n-a-m-e
as a column in our data set and that
doesn't exist and that's sort of the
error that we get
because we're trying to subset on an n a
so the problem is we need a way to treat
a variable as a variable
not as the quoted item there is a train
running across my window so if you hear
rumble that's what that is
um so if we want to unquote
um so the thing is we want to actually
unquote call name
get the parameter that the user passed
in and then quote it back
and use species in our subsetting
function
and so that's where you see this bang
bang operator these two exclamation
marks
and what that does is it actually
unquotes
the variable that we passed in so now if
we say
call name is species and then we we can
use
uh pass in
bang bang call name and what that will
do is it'll unquote it'll take call name
turn it into species and then pass that
into our function
so that's what that bang bang operator
is doing so how do you know if a
function actually
uh quotes its inputs so you first try to
run the function as is and then try to
run that parameter outside
so if we ran penguins an island
but we just ran island on its own you'll
see that the first option
it actually runs without error and a
second option it can't find island
and we've seen this like in our normal
day-to-day our programming
if we library our lang our lang is
probably not a variable that you have
and so like
library is another function that quotes
its inputs
so at the end of the day this bang bang
unquoting is really just
selective evaluation on parts of a
quoted expression so it's something
that's quoted
but i actually want you to unquote that
one little bit because i want to
pass in some other user input
and so bang bang bang is bang bang for
dot dot dot right so
that is probably a sentence you didn't
know was a sentence until right now
but essentially that is what the triple
explanation mark uh is for
and so what is bang bang bang um it is
how do we pass in or selectively unquote
a
list of things and so we can have a
bunch of expressions
using experts and say species island
year
and then we get a actually a list object
back
and then if we pass in that list object
to our selection
it doesn't know what to do with that so
then what we say is hey
take those expressions sort of unpack it
and then
like evaluate that list right so
evaluate that dot dot dot
and then we can actually uh use our
selection function
to do that d plier on its own actually
has one more check
um so
you can sort of have this mixed series
of columns so we can pass in species as
a column name and pass in column name
there
and then we can also use uh bang bang a
column name
uh and it'll selectively unquote that so
d plier allows both sections and
our currently our current function
doesn't work that way
and the way for us to make our function
behave more like d player
we have to learn a thing about closures
which is a quote and a closure
and so if i say closure we've probably
all seen
some error essentially along the lines
of object of type closure is not
subsettable
and typically the reason is because we
are writing in our code something like
df
bracket one um and that's because df is
actually an r function that's built into
the stats library the built-in stats
library
so what we're actually doing when we uh
do this sometimes
if we didn't specify df as a variable is
we're trying to subset a function
and if you try to subset like select
from the
player that doesn't make sense and
that's you'll get the same exact error
so what exactly is a closure a closure
is something
like a function or an expression plus
its environment
so what is an environment well we can
create a new environment using the base
r function called new.m and we can say
in this environment
create a variable x assign it to three
and the thing is if we in our regular
global environment just say x
it doesn't exist right it'll you'll get
an object x not found
but and if we try to say like hey
use that x variable right so like 3 plus
x
it doesn't exist but if we say 3 plus x
and then also pass in this environment e
that contains the definition of
x it'll work right so that's what
environments are
and so uh formulas actually encapsulate
an expression and its environment it's
not just for models
and so if you say like tilde three plus
three you actually get the expression
three plus three back and that's why you
see the tilde being used throughout the
tidy verse
it's sort of the quick way of quoting
something
and so we can actually subset formula
objects like the first object is always
going to be the tilde and we can get
different expression parts out of it
and we can evaluate them so formulas
is a form of an expression plus an
environment and so what we can do
is we can take a formula we can take a
separate environment
and then we can run this eval pass in
the formula expression
and then pass in the environment of the
formula and have it
evaluate uh the formula expression in a
given environment
right so a closure instead of like that
um that formula is really an expression
plus the environment so it's not it's a
different
like object but it's really a subclass
of formula without the little tilde bit
and this allows quasi quotation and so
the user might use the tilde but from
the developer's point of view you'll be
working with
closures and so closures behave very
similar to functions in that there's
this part that's the expression
and then there's this other part that is
the environment and then what you can do
is run eval tidy on a quota object and
then it'll say
okay i know the expression bit i know
the environment bit i'll run those two
bits together
and so closure is in practice we
actually don't use um
that new closure function
but that sort of exists in the world of
our lang for completeness sake
so the last bit of tidy eval is this
concept
of a data mask and so essentially data
mask is a
data frame or a list that essentially
when you try to
run code that's where it starts looking
for variables first
so it supersedes the actual environment
in terms of
variable lookup so think of a you can
also think of it as like this is a
environment that goes before the current
actual environment
where variables to look for
so what we can do is we can create a
closure using new closure
and then we can pass in a data frame
that says y of one to five and then in
eval tidy we can pass in the
closure expression and a data frame or
or the data parameter
and so right now our expression is x
times y
the enclosure itself has the value 100
for x
and when we say run x times y with x
equals 100 and pass in a data object of
of our y values we'll get the 100 200
300 400 500
so it's using that data object as a way
as a place to
look for additional variables and you
can see at the bottom there
if we try to run it on its own without
this infrastructure of
dealing with environments we get
different uh it either doesn't work
or if we want to totally replicate our
example we would simply say 100 times df
dollar y
so that's exactly what that eval tidy
function is doing under the hood
so in our previous try we handled the
weirdness we unquoted the arguments we
found the index positions and then we
did regular r things to return our data
set
uh but it didn't deal with the fact that
we passed in call name
um by itself and so we use the data mask
for that
and so we still handle the same
weirdness uh and essentially you can see
here
i'm using set name sequence along to get
the
all of the columns of our data frame and
i'm running eval tidy
to say like hey all of those inputs
evaluate them in this context so i can
get the actual column name back and then
you know just to handle the fact that
sometimes a user might pass in a
character string we dealt with that too
but at the end of the day select arrange
tidy select all of that stuff all it's
doing is getting
a vector of index positions back and
then returning that
back to you using base r that's penguins
d index and then drop equals faults so
there's a lot of things i didn't cover
for example there's this colon equals
operator that essentially lets you quote
things to the
left hand side of an equal sign i also
didn't talk about
uh pronouns like data and dot m so you
can read more about those
but the tl dr is if the user
if you want the user to pass in a string
and the function itself internally uses
a string
that's something that we're all used to
so for example gdpr has an aes string
option
and we can use our function as is if you
want the user to pass in a string but
the function takes a quote
what you want to do is convert it to an
expression first and then unquote the
expression so we can use
aes with bang bang there if the
you want the user to pass in a quote
which is essentially without the
quotations mark so the actual
code and then the function itself takes
a string
um you capture the expression using an
exper
convert it convert the string to an
expression so there is
an r lang as string and then you can
execute that as is
and then if you want the user to pass in
a quote and the function itself also
takes a quote
you first have to use end quo
to capture the quotation and then
unquote
unquoted
and that's where you see this curly
curly embrace
notation in our lang it's essentially
doing that quoting and unquoting for you
and so with that um there is this meta
programming chapter
in advance r and i've probably read that
like once a month for the last year
so just keep reading that until you
eventually get it is sort of what i
ended up doing
so thank you thank you very much dan
that's awesome stream starting soon it's
awesome love dance technology as always
he always brings it both on screen
technology and others
so that was really great with that folks